in this video we're going to think about
marginal revenue and marginal cost for a
firm in an imperfectly competitive
market but before we do that i just want
to be able to review and compare to what
we already know about a firm in a
perfectly competitive market so right
over here we're analyzing the firm's
economics this shows the marginal cost
as a function of quantity and we've
talked about this before
oftentimes it will trend down initially
as you have better specialization and
some efficiencies and then it might
start trending up as they're just
coordination costs or other costs that
make the marginal cost go up
and we have talked about this notion
that in a perfectly competitive market
the firm is a price taker there's going
to be some market price let's call this
p
sub m some price in the market for the
good that they are producing and there's
many producers who are producing this
good and they're undifferentiated and
there's no barriers to entry and so they
just have to be price takers there no
matter how many units they produce
they're just going to be able to get
that same market price
so a firm in a perfectly competitive
market that market price defines their
marginal revenue curve their marginal
revenue curve will essentially just be a
horizontal line
like this and we've already studied this
in previous videos and we talked about
that here if this firm was trying to
maximize its profit and if it was
rational it would produce the quantity
where marginal cost is equal to marginal
revenue so it would produce this
quantity right over here but now let's
think about how things are a bit
different for a firm in an imperfectly
competitive market in a previous video
we talked about how in an imperfectly
competitive market there's some
differentiation amongst the various
players who are competing and so they
their market price is a function of
quantity if they just produce a bunch of
their product the price that they get in
the market is likely to go down so they
will have their own
firm specific demand curve maybe it
looks something like this
so that is their demand curve and we
also saw in that video that that demand
curve essentially the price that they
could get at any quantity that that's
not going to be the same as a marginal
revenue curve if the demand curve is
downward sloping like that the marginal
revenue curve is likely to be even more
downward sloping so it's going to be
look something like this that would be
the marginal revenue curve now in this
situation what would be rational for the
firm to do
well once again it would want to produce
the quantity where the marginal cost is
equal to the marginal revenue so they
would want to produce this quantity
right over here but you see something
interesting here if they produce at this
quantity
notice the price that they can get in
the market is much higher than that the
price that they get in the market is
higher than the marginal cost and the
marginal revenue at that point and
because we see a situation where price
is greater than your marginal cost
versus in a perfectly competitive market
where you see that price is equal to
marginal cost that that is the optimal
quantity but because you have this gap
that people are willing to pay more than
that marginal cost but you still aren't
going to be able to produce any more
because it doesn't make sense from a
marginal revenue point of view this gap
the difference between the price and the
marginal cost at this rational quantity
for this firm in an imperfectly
competitive market to produce economists
would refer to this as an inefficiency
inefficiency
folks are willing to pay more than that
marginal cost but you still have no
motivation to produce more because if
you produce more even though the price
is higher than the marginal cost your
marginal revenue is going to be below
the marginal cost and so you would be
taking a hit in aggregate on those extra
units